what a correctional officer was exposed
to inside a Nevada prison remains a
mystery so this is a story the 8 news
now in this invest first broke
Essa Murphy has obtained an internal
memo about what may have happened
the substance the officer was exposed to
was initially believed to be fentanyl
but a Nevada Department of Corrections
spokesman now tells me testing was done
Hazmat even got involved and it's still
unclear exactly what the substance was
still we've learned there will be some
changes at High Desert State Prison
that's about a 40-minute drive outside
of Las Vegas and those changes include
adding additional Narcan inside the
prison now Narcan is a medication which
helps reverse an opioid overdose it can
save a life this is an internal memo
we've obtained stating Narcan will be
distributed in each housing unit for
emergency use and the department
requested and received more of it from
the division of Health and Human
Services the memo also States any staff
member searching or handling inmates
property must wear gloves and an n95
mask the memo also reveals more about
the January 4th incident stating the off
officer was exposed to an unknown
substance during a cell search which
placed the officer in serious medical
distress Narcan was used the officer was
taken to the hospital and is recovering
at home now the memo is signed by the
acting Warden who thanked staff who
responded to the emergency for their
quick thinking which quote saved the
life of one of their own end quote as
we've reported there has been an issue
with drugs getting inside High Desert
and other prisons James arenda returned
as the Department of Corrections
director on Monday he tells me he plans
on addressing the issue and he wants to
start discussions about possibly
scanning personal mail entering the
prisons Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
the eight news now investigators have
uncovered numerous issues at the
Department of Corrections and you can
watch previous reports at 8newsnow.com